cannes sans la censure deux films
étaient en compétition officielle
aujourd'hui pola x de leos carax avec
catherine deneuve et guillaume depardieu
il a reçu un accueil plutôt frisquet ce
matin sifflé lors de sa présentation à
la presse
deuxième film ce soir kadosh ce qui veut
dire sacré en hébreu un film d'amos
gitaï sur la société israélienne
aujourd'hui une coproduction étrangères
qui prêtent à polémique qu'elle a même
été censuré en israël reportage
michel vial laurent suau christian
welter c'est le premier film israélien
en compétition depuis moshé mizrahi en
1974 kadosh amos gitaï raconte
l'histoire de deux soeurs qui vivent
dans le quartier juif ultra orthodoxe de
jérusalem marié et heureux en couple
depuis dix ans l'aîné ne peut avoir
d'enfant et se trouve répudier sur ordre
du rabbin tandis que sa cadette refuse
le fiancé qu'on lui dessine le blick qui
peuplent minaude les mots qu'il faut ce
film il parle il est situé dans les
quartiers orthodoxes de jérusalem
mais les questions qu'il pose une
question à la religion à large à
solvalla autres d'auxi les religions
elle même par son décret par son
conception real qui féminine sans
religion qui marginalise les boucles
position de la femme qui bat avec son
regard polémique sur la puissance
grandissante des religieux dans la
société
le film dérange en israël avec un sujet
brûlant en plein coeur du débat
électoral actuel le fric de maryse réel
ce un pays qui est toujours en train dé
change de chercher sa destin qu'est ce
qu'elle va devenir
est-ce qu'elle va être géré par des
clergé religieux hermétique ou est ce
qu'elle va rester en société ouverte
démocratique
c'est sûr qu'il ya des gens en israël
qui pensent
le contraire et qui diront à ma place
j'ai fait un film choquant qui monte sur
la réalité qui est brutal et setra et
ses traitements
mais voilà un pays démocratique ce débat
un débat de société dans lequel une fois
de plus le cinéma joue son rôle de
témoin voire d'acteur entre la politique
et la vie